-You directed
the horror movie of the year.
Not just the movie of the year
but the horror movie
of the year.
And you have long
been a fan of horror.
Back in the day, we saw plenty
of horror movies together.
You're a fan of Tim Burton.
-Yes.
Big fan of Tim Burton
growing up.
-"Beetlejuice"
is a big movie for you?
-[ Laughing ]
What do you got there?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, this is just my taxes.
-Okay. All right.
All right, hold on to that.
-So how old --
This is you dressing up
as Beetlejuice.
-That's me.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Pretty great.
-I used the same costume
for Garth,
from "Wayne's World,"
the next year.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, so that's --
You just got me
un-laid by my own wife.
-Oh, wow.
-By showing that.
-This moved you backwards.
Yeah, this moved you this far.
This is you laid,
and then, I just did this.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-That's great.
But that's young to have seen
"Beetlejuice," I feel like.
-Yeah, it was --
It scared me.
-Yeah, okay, good.
[ Laughter ]
She takes the face off.
No, it was --
No, that's one of the things
I loved about Tim Burton
is that he entertained
and scared at the same time.
He just
has this very specific mix.
So hats off to you, Tim Burton.
-And Michael Keaton
just literally
one of the greatest
actors alive.
-Yeah.
Amazing performance.
I mean, I wonder
how Michael Keaton feels
that, like, his entire life --
He's put some amazing
performances together,
and people must
just be like "Beetlejuice, man."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-"Aah!"
"I didn't --
I didn't do the face thing.
That was prosthetics."
"No, you did it."
Yeah.
-"Do you have people say,
'Do the face thing'?"
-"Do it, do it!"
Yeah.
-You had fantastic actors
in your film, as well.
-Yes.
-Daniel Kaluuya,
who's fantastic.
Keener, Bradley Whitford.
-Mm-hmm.
-And Allison Williams.
And Allison Williams
was here recently,
and I heard that she came to you
because she needed help
with a scene.
-Yes. So this --
One day, she just --
She calls me, and she says --
You know, there's
a love scene in the movie.
It's not like a hot,
steamy sex scene.
I would not feel comfortable
directing that.
I just don't --
That's not my style.
But it was like this soft,
sweet love scene,
and she calls me,
and she's like,
"Look, I really need to practice
that love scene with Daniel,
and I'm gonna invite him over.
Can you come and, like --
Can we work this out?"
This was like
my worst nightmare.
[ Laughter ]
"Like, okay, so I have to go --
Okay, I have to go to your house
and like witness you
doing this weird love --
like direct it?
Like, come on.
This is --"
Yeah, just absolute --
absolute nightmare.
"Okay, I'm a director now.
I'm an enigmatic,
intelligent director.
I have to man up.
So I went over to the house,
and, of course,
it was a surprise party for me.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Oh, that's fantastic.
-It was very sweet.
At which point I realized,
of course, Allison Williams
does not need coaching
with love scenes.
[ Laughter ]
She's fine.
[ Both laugh ]
-She also told me,
which sounded fantastic,
is that, again,
your unique situation,
where you're a director,
not only an actor
but an incredible
sketch performer, as well,
that you would sometimes direct,
if it called for it,
as Tracy Morgan
and sometimes as Barack Obama.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
If you needed to pick up
the room a little bit, you know,
you can just be like,
[ As Obama ]
"All right, now, and cut!
All right, let's...
You know,
that's pretty good.
It's pretty good."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"But it's, uh...
I think we can do
a little bit better."
[ Laughter ]
"Let's learn our lines,
for starters.
That'd be a big help."
And, you know,
this is one of those things
where, like,
the audience is ready for this
to go to a punch line.
[ Laughter ]
It's not. it's just a voice.
-Punch line --
When would you direct --
What would be the scene you
would need Tracy Morgan for?
-Tracy Morgan was somehow a more
competent director than Obama.
[ As Tracy Morgan ]
"All right, stop, let's go!
Hey, let's go!
Everybody, let's get this --
We're gonna be movin'.
We got to be there
in 60 seconds!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
"We got to be there --"
Tracy -- Tracy is, uh --
Tracy's a good friend of mine.
He's like a brother to me.
-And you're producing
a show with him, yeah?
-I'm producing a show with him,
starring him, Tiffany Haddish.
-Oh, fantastic.
-Cedric the Entertainer.
Amazing cast.
-That's incredible.
-It's on TBS.
It's called "The Last O.G."
-Mm-hmm.
-And it's just a super funny
show, and Tracy is amazing.
And one day --
This is --
I was talking to him
on the phone,
and he was eating something.
He's like, "Mm. Sorry.
I'm eating a Ding Dong
right now."
[ Laughter ]
Like, "All right, no problem,"
And he starts talking to me.
All of a sudden,
he starts coughing violently.
[ Coughing loudly ]
It's like,
"Tracy, are you okay?"
[ Coughing ] "Yeah, yeah.
I'm Tracy Morgan.
Survived getting hit by a truck,
killed by a Ding Dong!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Classic line.
-Well, I can't wait for that.
-Yeah.
-I can't wait for everything
that's coming next for you.
I'm just an audience
that can't wait for more.
Congratulations on everything
this year, Jordan.
-Thank you, man.
-It's just fantastic.
Jordan Peele, everybody!